RuPaul's Drag Race stars Monet exchange
and Nina West have received some major
backlash this week after appearing on
the view to help celebrate outspoken
Republican Meghan McCain's
35th birthday and naming her an official
root girl
[Applause]
and we thought it would only be
appropriate if we made you an official
root girl and give you fans of drag race
and members of the lgbtq+ community were
very unhappy with both monet and nina
including other RuPaul's Drag Race stars
like Katya who simply called it gross
and winners Bianca Del Rio and aquaria
agreed last night Monet posted multiple
Instagram stories about the backlash and
explained why she has no apology for
appearing on the view so Nina and I have
been getting a lot of backlash regarding
the view second that we did the other
day and I'm of course side with you
things to say not terrible
number one Meghan became isn't how I she
is y'all love to pick and choose and
decide when and allies be is convenient
for you that's not how life works it's
not how the universe works she is an
ally Meghan McCain has done a lot for
the lgbtqia+ community being on the view
does not mean that I endorse all of
Meghan McCain's views we probably
disagree puppy 90% but the fact is that
I can still have tolerance I can still
have the decorum to do to want and to
have a conversation
Meghan is married to a co-founder of a
website which has accused parents of
manipulating children into gender
transition and has called for puberty
blockers to be made illegal something
Monet recognizes yes Meghan McCain's
husband is problematic 100 150 percent
but to hold Meghan to blame Megan for
her husband's behavior is blaming women
for what their husbands are doing just
say 19:02 just because you're gay don't
make your now I that's a word that's
team now Monet also stands firm that
having representation on a show like the
view is important who knows because it
is now a decent of you to be open to
having more drag queens more trans
people more more gay men more lesbians
more none but everything now what we
invited us to be co-hosts now we can
have a seat at the table and have big a
conversation that actual conversation
Nina West has always been applauded for
being a huge activist and advocate for
the LG
TQ plus community but hasn't said much
about her appearance on the view with
the exception of responding to a few
tweets and also this week drag race fans
were gagged with an announcement that
there will be a RuPaul's celebrity drag
race which will include cisgender
straight men fans are upset because the
series has been reluctant to include
non-binary cisgendered women trans and
drag king performers both Nina and Monet
are confirmed to take part on the series
so what do you think of Monet and Nina
appearing on the view and calling Megan
an official route girl do you think
because someone is Republican they
cannot truly support the lgbtq+
community how are you feeling about a
celebrity edition of RuPaul's Drag Race
let me know in the comments below and
don't forget to subscribe to ET Canada's
YouTube page
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]